es ist endlich eine gute nachricht im
fall einer havarie ist aus seinem
künstlichen koma wieder erwacht die
ärzte holen ihnen jetzt langsam zurück
ins leben nachdem in russland vergiftet
worden war
mit russischen nervengift und vor der
berliner charité wo alexej nawalny noch
immer behandelt wird steht jetzt mein
kollege peter hellmann peter sack uns
wie soll es ihm aktuell gehen
naja nach 16 tagen koma haben die ärzte
der charité folgendes bekannt gegeben
es geht ihm besser ist stabil er soll
sogar auch auf ansprache reagieren was
immer das heißen mag das kann ein
blinzeln sein das kann ein fingerdruck
sein
er wird langsam von der mechanischen
beatmungsmaschine entwöhnt ganz langsam
heruntergefahren
er ist auch ganz langsam aus dem koma
herausgeholt worden
und das sind so die gesundheitlichen
einzelheiten die wir bislang mitbekommen
haben seine frau julia wacht nach wie
vor jeden tag am bett ihres mannes und
die charité will sich vermutlich diese
woche noch etwas genauer einlassen was
den gesundheitszustand von alex navalny
anbelangt was allerdings nicht so
positiv ist dass die ärzte
langzeitfolgen durch dieses extrem
gefährliche nervengift eben nicht
ausschließen können dass dieses
nervengift geht an die organe
beziehungsweise auch das zentrale
nervensystem an das können ganz
schreckliche spätfolgen zur folge haben
was ganz interessant ist in diesem
zusammenhang ist gerade im hintergrund
von diesem krimi hat jetzt die russische
ärztekammer die deutsche ärztekammer
angeschrieben das berichtet auf jeden
fall das deutsche ärzteblatt und wollen
eine gemeinsame kommission bilden als
sie möchten das eben
ergebnisse auch ausgetauscht werden über
diesen weg medizinische ergebnisse um
eben festzustellen ob er wirklich mit
novak vergiftet worden ist das wiederum
bestätigte gestern eben auch der
cdu-innenexperte patrick sensburg der
bestätigte noch mal was eigentlich klar
war dass eben westliche
nachrichtendienste wahrscheinlich auch
der bundesnachrichtendienst abgleiche
proben hat von diesem gefährlichen
nervengift novy schock das heißt man
kann es im prinzip abgleichen wie ein
fingerabdruck dann weiß man das ist nur
wie job und die experten sind offenbar
so weit dass sie auch sagen können in
welchem labor das hergestellt worden ist
also die schlinge zieht sich immer mehr
zu es gibt offenbar gar keinen zweifel
mehr dass es sich um dieses nervengift
handelt es gibt keinen zweifel dass es
aus russischer produktion kommt und das
führt eben daneben auch zu dem täter hin
russland nämlich mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren